[Music]
it's signed full of roses and rose'
today we had to use my scarf because we
lost one of our Rose blankets touch on
journalism it's about transparency so
everybody tonight the episode was pretty
much all about Corinne and we learned
that Corinne has three feet horny I
definitely know how to turn on the
section bobbing and unconscious first
grant tried to seduce Nick with some
whipped cream because she acts pretty
much like a teenager and I guess she
thinks best sexy take it off I do
and then Karina had a total meltdown
because she acts like a teenager and I
guess he thinks Beth normal I know who
stupid owes Nick and I just honestly do
not even have a chance and then grant
fell asleep Corinne is missing at the
rose ceremony then we had some very big
guest stars the Backstreet Boys oh my
god Oh Nick Kevin Brian Howey AJ hello
I wanted this is that way anyway that
they allow I wanted all the ways okay
but of course even the Backstreet Boys
could not upstage a Corinne she provided
commentary like this plan dancing is one
of like being connection what's the
Concord yeah so I wrote a little song in
currents honor tell me why can't Corinne
seem to stay awake tell me why does she
not know the word choreography what's
the conquering yeah tell me why cuz I
never again want to hear Corinne say hey
she wants it her way harder B result
because it's Carly's going to be myself
it's making me real more know myself I
did not memorize that I discreetly
glanced down at this piece of paper it
was not discrete was okay the ladies had
to do a little choreography contest to
win the group date with the Backstreet
Boys Corinne did not win I want to suck
yeah but I was a little bit shocked
because professional dancer Jasmine did
not take home the trophy
it was nail salon owner Danielle I am
predicting the top three now Rachel
Vanessa and yeah whoo dreams if I'm
wrong oh no we don't know just drinking
anyway
Corinne didn't win and again in a very
normal reaction
she said that watching Nick was another
woman is her quote worst nightmare my
worst nightmare repeated over and over
and over and over and over
okay so again remember Corinne did not
know the word choreography my guess
works we are reminded that Kerwin who is
24 - and I'm really juggling trying to
appreciate everything that is Corinne
she thinks her that my bed is made every
morning makes my cucumber and then she
says the mani mixer cheese pasta and
cheese pasta I have tried so many times
making Papa no mac and cheese grin say
get a dictionary and make your own food
and bag okay you know on the other hand
all I got to say if Corinth is living
all of our best lives I mean she calls
her a nanny I call her a personal
assistant and I want one here's the
Quran if someone cutting up your
cucumber on sunlight mr. Ravi and I'm
not going to stop a woman talking so
Vanessa yes the national one of the best
Russian zoom in this house please he
goes on a one-on-one date with Nick this
date was pretty cool they were
weightless in a plane it was very
romantic but Memphis hair looks amazing
but then Sarah would not smell amazing
did he grow through up mm-hm and then he
kisses her again yes this is a show that
makes sane people do insane things I
would not make out with someone after
vomiting and I would judge someone if
you wanted to make out with me after
vomit they even comment on it gross
okay so then there's another group date
something with four words I don't know I
can to to now so that
know your audience and then a girl who I
don't recognize and whose name I don't
know is upset that nicka I notice her
none of us have been now I gotta give
props and a dream to Nick here and
because Nick was very honest with her
and you're just like look things are
going well with so many other women and
what with you and to what's-her-name
left banks instead of doing a cocktail
party they do a pall party everyone's in
a bikini so Corinne somehow manages to
corral a bouncy house what are we doing
having fun and her Nick of bouncing
around in it and everything something
around there you down see the other
women shockingly don't approve tensions
are starting to arrive so at the end of
the episode we reach the piling on
current phase and you know it always
goes well on the bachelor bachelorette
when you sell the lead that other people
are cycle it makes you look super saying
I think you are making a huge mistake
with Mike Rowe
Curren well we're going to get to see
all of that next week so Cheers the
Corinne he's living her best like she
wants to be Nick's wife giving the other
lady strikes and she wants it her way
[Music]
guys thank you so much for watching make
sure to subscribe to easy on YouTube we
are recapping The Bachelor here every
week and also like us on Facebook
because we have many bachelor and
bachelorettes alumni there every Tuesday
to help us talk about Monday night's
episode also you can follow me on
Twitter snapchat Instagram everything
ending on a win take it one you can get
it just like The Bachelor
you